[Música]
vamos ahora a cambiar de tema vamos con
nuestro primer invitado del día porque
el viernes el tribunal es superior
electoral de Brasil inhabilitó al
expresidente Jair bolsonaro por un
periodo de ocho años tras dictaminar que
difundió informaciones sin fundamento
que pusieron en duda la legitimidad del
sistema electoral todo eso durante su
fallida campaña por la reelección sobre
el futuro político del líder y su
movimiento vamos a conversar con Rafael
RCN quien es doctor en sociología e
investigador en la universidad Federal
de Río de Janeiro Muchísimas gracias soy
Rafael por estar con nosotros
Muchísimas gracias a ustedes por mi
invitar bueno para comenzar la defensa
dijo que recurrirá ante el supremo
tribunal Federal es posible a uno para
usted revertir este fallo
claro Hay caminos para recurrir o sea
caminos legales pero los caminos
políticos son muy difíciles Por qué
Porque la suprema corte de Brasil la más
grande corte judicial de Brasil está
toda muy involucrada en un intento de
cercar y
y no dejar pasar este movimiento
que hubo fue un intento de golpe en
Brasil y claro también Enviar un mensaje
a la sociedad y a los políticos de
Brasil que no se aceptan en Brasil
cualquier intento golpista cualquier
amenaza a la democracia brasileña o sea
tiene un camino legal pero lo camino
político para bolsonar o es muy difícil
Bueno
me agrada que hable sobre ese tema
porque precisamente lo que queremos aquí
es entender qué va a pasar con la
carrera política de Jair bolsonaro
porque en 2030 cuando acabe la
inhabilitación si es que no sucede algo
adverso antes
ya 75 años y aquí muchos se preguntan si
murió políticamente Jair bolsonaro
Bueno Este es una duda que tenemos todos
podemos pensar que bolsonaro murió como
candidato o sea porque en ocho años es
muy difícil mantenerse fuerte
electoralmente en Brasil pero podemos
decir que está vivo muy vivo como líder
de un movimiento sabe que tiene cuatro
hijos tres que ya están adentro de la
política uno que está afuera hay una
quinta hija pero es una niña no puede
participar de momentos políticos tiene
su mujer micheli y tiene muchos
políticos de Brasil que tienen bolsonaro
como un liderazgo o sea puede no estar
listo para candidatarse o sea legalmente
Pero puede seguir como un liderazgo muy
importante de la extrema derecha
brasileña bueno y guardando las
proporciones si lo comparamos con el
caso del propio Lula da Silva que hoy
regresa a la presidencia después de
también haber tenido cualquier suerte de
delirios legales después de haber estado
Incluso en la cárcel Usted cree que la
justicia brasileña va da la cabida para
que Jair bolsonaro se recupere de este
golpe
en este momento creo que sea muy difícil
Como dijo quieren Enviar un mensaje a la
sociedad de que lo que hizo bolsonaro no
puede ser nadie en Brasil o sea que
nadie puede atacar la democracia en
Brasil que
luchamos mucho para tener que tenemos
desde 1988 cuando
empezó la nueva constitución brasileña
Yo sé que este jueces están trabajando
para garantizar que esta Constitución de
88 lo que llamamos acá de Constitución
ciudadana
siga siga siendo respetada por todos los
políticos en Brasil el tema es que ahora
haya bolsonaro además de este caso le
quedan pendientes otras cuentas con la
justicia Cómo se vincula este caso por
ejemplo con la toma de Brasilia en enero
podría servir como base para otros
procesos que transcurren en contra del
ex mandatario
yo creo que sí creo que es todo parte de
un gran proceso político que es un
proceso judicial pero también un proceso
político que tiene que ver con los
intentos de de bolsonaro y su grupo
político que tenían militares
empresarios gente de la sociedad civil
para hacer un golpe en Brasil un intento
que empieza antes de las elecciones y
que tiene su punto máximo en el día ocho
de enero de dos mil dos cuando intentan
tomar los palacios de Brasilia o sea
creo que esto todo es parte de un mismo
movimiento y que tiene también un contra
movimiento que es el movimiento del
sistema judicial en el sistema político
para frenar este intentos golpistas del
grupo de bolsonaro bueno Rafael y usted
hace un momento mencionaba a Michelle
bolsonaro que podría ser previsiblemente
sucesora pues de su esposo pero quiero
preguntarle usted opina que Michelle
bolsonaroso sería capaz de llenar el
vacío político que dejaría el ex
mandatario
yo creo que ella tiene la capacidad de
ser un liderazgo Pero
hay muchos problemas que enfrentar uno
para mí lo más importante es que es el
bolsonarismo es un movimiento muy
masculino o sea tiene la idea de un
hombre fuerte del hombre como el líder
de la familia lo que llaman familia
tradicional tiene una idea de la fuerza
de las armas del Poder y y que sea muy
difícil para una mujer que es imprevista
como frágil como que debe trabajar
adentro de casa cuidando la familia que
sea el liderazgo de este movimiento
además tenía que pelear con los tres
hijos de bolsonaro que están en la
política
uno de ellos también tienen problemas
con la justicia involucrado con casos de
corrupción en Río de Janeiro y también
con otros liderazgos políticos del
movimiento del bolsonaro Como por
ejemplo el general bragan neto que es
muy probable que sea candidata a
concejal de Río de Janeiro el actual
gobernador de de la provincia del estado
de San Pablo tarsicio O sea hay otros
liderazgos adentro del bolsonaro
peleando por este local de Liderazgo
bien y ya para mi última pregunta nos
queda menos de un minuto sin bolsonaro
Cómo debe reorganizarse la ultraderecha
en el país que va a pasar con el
bolsonarismo en sí mismo Porque de todas
maneras es un movimiento con fuerza
sí es un movimiento con mucha fuerza que
sigue teniendo apoyo de más o menos 20
25% de la población en Brasil logró
elegir muchos diputados gobernadores o
sea Creo que van a seguir muy vivos
incluso porque el bozonarismo logró
llevar el centro de la política más a
derecha entonces toda la política
brasileña se volvió más de derecho y por
eso tienen mucha fuerza política en
Brasil y no sé van a pelear en los
próximos años para ver quién va a ser el
gran liderazgo de este movimiento que
sigue muy vivo pues muchísimas gracias
es Rafael reciente doctor en sociología
e investigador en la universidad Federal
de Río de Janeiro Que tenga feliz día
Muchas gracias chao a nuestros
televidentes continúen con nosotros
hacemos una pequeña pausa pero ya
volvemos con más noticias
[Música]